our next guests have been training long
and hard for the upcoming 2024 Olympics
in Paris fun fact between the three of
them they've won over 60 National medals
please welcome from the USA artistic
swimming team Anita Alvarez Natalia Vega
Daniela Ramirez
[Applause]
Anita how do you train as an artistic
swimmer yeah so it's it's pretty crazy
we train six days a week anywhere from
six to ten hours a day so it's it's a
full-time job minus the regular income
so it's it's a lot and you know we
relocate we're a team sport so we have
to train all together in one location so
we relocate from all over the country
you know some girls are still in high
school they leave their high schools and
do homeschool some are in college so
it's a lot of commitment and we you know
we miss out on regular activities
birthday parties weddings dating
holidays dating how do you even approach
that we don't usually have a lot of time
on our hands so we can't just be
willy-nilly like oh I can go on a date
with you this day or I can spend some
time with you here like we have very
regimented days so going from like 6 30
in the morning until 3 P.M we're at
practice and then after that anything is
like a very hard thing to go out of your
bed to not be recovering your muscles
during the day so it can work but it's
it gets really hard to do I mean dating
for me is not that hard I'm also dating
an athlete and we've been together for
six years so I feel like they understand
how hard our schedule is and like what
our sport takes and like all the
sacrifices we have to make so
if you find an athlete it makes it a
little bit easier I was gonna say maybe
maybe that's why like actors date actors
and maybe
yes you you have a built-in
understanding and empathy
so okay so that's your dating life my
dating life
good okay yeah I I'm dating I date uh
which is nice much more proactive than I
was uh for several years I have a very
full life it's not my first priority but
I was like figuring out because we're
all in it we're all trying to navigate
this life and this world and when you
have something that is your passion and
your priority it does tend to eat up the
majority of your time and I think a lot
of people just relate to that well I'm
so excited
um as you saw Rita Ora and I talking and
dishing all things hair our show is
actually teaming up with Tresemme today
um and your team is working with them
and they probably tell us about the
partnership so yeah we partnered up with
Tresemme and we've created this
beautiful underwater film we're
promoting their new line the pro
infusion line by Tresemme this film is
so beautiful yes you can see it like it
really showcases the fluidity of our
hair which was the main point we're
super excited for this partnership
gorgeous that is and Daniella why did
you find making this film so empowering
so in our regular routine when we do do
performances we have our hair super
tight and tied back with gelatin which
is what we it's like the thing you use
to make jello so it's very hard and it
hardens in our hair and it makes you
feel like you're kind of Trapped so we
wanted to feel more free and fluid and
as women we like to express express
ourselves with our hair and I feel like
with this film we were able to finally
find a way to do artistic swimming in a
way where we feel free and fluid and
underwater we can really really like see
how the water
plays with the hair and it was just
really really fun it's so funny I'm
totally relating
I've worn many
many films
under the bald cap or the cap and your
hair is shellacked and it's up in the
pins all day and you get that like hair
headache and then you take it down
you're like ah and it feels so good I
would have never known we had things in
common I'm so glad too and Drew I heard
you actually uh were able to try our
sport one time we would love to hear
about that you know what I did actually
Ross and I uh that's us we did a segment
out in Los Angeles and we had so much
fun and it gave me a deep respect and
understanding for the sport I'd never
done anything like it
[Applause]
[Music]